two things I can always plead right when
I'll be dead by 2015 so it won't matter
to me and second as a historian I always
look back rather than forward but those
aren't fair excuses for this I think
that unless the the countries of Europe
figure out an accommodation with these
populations it's going to be disastrous
it's going to be increasingly increasing
numbers of riots increasing divisions
not only along economic lines but along
religious and ethnic lines and it will
be a disaster I mean I think for me that
the the most interesting thing I've seen
and it's not a perfect document was the
the Bouchard Taylor report that came out
of Quebec do you know about this it's a
report the Charles Taylor the
philosopher and jihad Gousha I can't
remember what he does were asked to
write a report about the accommodation
of Muslims in Quebec and there it was a
particularly hot issue because Quebec is
secular although there's a large
Catholic population that wants to press
very hard for control in or political
influence in certain ways and they came
up with a report about a common what
accommodation and where to draw the
lines and what mattered and what didn't
matter and I thought it was the most
sensible document I'd seen in a really
long time because it requires adherence
to the prints of the political
principles of the nation and of the
region Democratic ones Republican ones
at the same time that it's pluralist in
its tolerance and its tolerance is the
wrong word because as one of my friends
keep saying tolerance means it you you
you abide by something you don't really
like I think recognition is the better
the better term so you recognize that
there are certain kinds of practices
that need to be respected on the part of
Muslim populations praying five times a
day for those who do places where you
can wash your feet or and your hands
before you pray on the other hand you
say we draw the line here
you're in a hospital and the only doctor
on is a male doctor and you're a woman
you take it which in fact many of the
interpreters of the of the Koran will
tell you is is already there to be to be
or of Hadees that come out of it crime
it's already understood to be to be a
practice and so on
but so you know here are the lines
here's what constitutes respect and
recognition here's what constitutes the
limit that can be placed on the kinds of
demands that can be made of a more
general public and of a more a more
multicultural public can't impose your
will your truth on all of us so it seems
to me that that's the kind of
accommodation that's the kind of policy
that has to be developed whether or not
it will is another question there's also
a group a group of feminists in France
who are Muslim feminists hits who wear
the hijab and French feminists that is
we would call them white but you know
that French French I'll say dis Uche
they called native French I mean all of
these terms are loaded and it's very
difficult to use them but okay so
they're secular French women and
headscarf Muslim French women and they
came up with a statement of principle
which seems to me to offer some of the
answers and it is we are for equality in
all realms we are against the
subordination of any groups or
individuals no forced wearing of
headscarves no forced removal of head
scarves and that seems to me to be to
sort of be pointing towards the kinds of
accommodation that Bouchard Taylor
offered in Quebec and that needs to be
really addressed and thought through not
only in France but in these in the
countries here I think if they don't do
it it's one doesn't even want to think
about what what the future the
difficulties the tensions the
humiliations the riot
you know think of the 2005 riots I mean
I think more and more of that will be
the case unless there's some really
serious effort to pick up some of these
suggestions that have been made and work
with them